de quoi pas vos chansons n'importe quoi
pour lequel j'ai écrit une chanson sur
ma grand mère qui est probablement la
femme que j'ai préféré tout celle que
j'ai rencontré dans ma vie j'ai écrit
des chansons sur le fait de courir loin
de soi même j'écris des chansons sur les
romances traditionnelle entre hommes et
femmes
j'écris des chansons sur l'amitié comme
li na demi prof d'habitude les gens
écrivent des chansons sur une sorte
d'amour l'amour pour quelque chose avant
pour les voitures par exemple chaque
berry a écrit des chansons sur l'amour
qu'on peut avoir pour les voitures c'est
toujours sur une sorte d'amour
quelconque mais généralement romantique
la sorte d'amour la moins sûre à moins
intéressant je crois que les amitiés
dure plus longtemps que les mariages les
gens qui sont simplement amis et qu'ils
peuvent et se dira l'un l'autre
si vous avez besoin de quelque chose
donnez le moi est ici je peux faire
quelque chose pour vous vous avez essayé
créer une chanson sur un relais jeunesse
elle convient d'écouter et bien c'est
aussi une chanson d'amour
j'en avais entendu parler très longtemps
de cet endroit c'est un nom qui a
énormément de poids par exemple un globe
trotter se sont pas du tout 2 mai pour
donner à l'équipe
nous sommes des d'identification eh bien
ils ont appelé alors j'étais toujours
fasciné par ce nom - m puisque je viens
tout à fait d'un autre ou une autre
partie 2
quand j'ai passé une semaine j'étais
tellement impressionné que j'écris une
chanson soirée c'est la première chanson
que j'ai jamais écrit et no sunshine de
wever son plus grand succès c'est un
petit garçon à ce que vous pensiez
devenir un grand chanteur non pas
vraiment en fait je me suis pas mis à
chanter professionnellement vont avoir
peut-être 31 ans quand j'étais petit
j'étais dans un tout petit bled
et puis je pensais devenir marin
ça me plaisait comité alors je suis
devenu marin une fission est et 9 ans et
puis je suis sorti de la marine en 1976
et puis à ce moment là j'ai commencé à
écouter les autres chanter et puis ça me
semblait un truc pas mal à faire bien
dans le coup alors j'ai économiser un
peu d'argent
j'ai fait un enregistrement et puis en
1969 j'ai été avec servane magnétique
voit un petit des maisons de disques et
personne ne m'aimait deux ans plus tard
le pianiste chute avec moi maintenant
jackson a donné cette bande à ma maison
de disques c'est lequel je travaille
maintenant
et puis moi pelé et voilà j'étais devenu
chanteur c'est donc commencé très tard
par rapport à ce qu'est la plupart des
artistes font d'habitude était déjà un
vieillard quand j'ai commencé et que
faisiez-vous avant d'être chambre j'ai
travaillé dans une compagnie
d'électronique et puis j'ai fabriqué des
voitures
et puis j'étais laitiers mon dernier
boulot avant de chanter c'était
fabricant de toilettes pour les avions
pour les 745 alors peut-être avez-vous
pris cet avion
peut-être avez-vous utilisé mes talents
parce que on peut se poser ainsi est-ce
que leur binôme blues est ce que la
musique noire qui a changé qu'il devrait
avoir changé pour nous aller dans une
autre direction
est ce que vous avez même sentiment un
secret qu'il se passe quelque chose je
crois que c'est la musique noire qui
devient plus intelligente maintenant il
a eu beaucoup d'influx ans
des paroles qui veulent vraiment dire
quelque chose
autrefois on chanter des paroles sur
n'importe quoi si ta femme veut pas
faire comme tu veux tu coupes la tête à
coups de hache des choses comme ça
qu'ils voulaient vraiment pas de grand
chose
et puis y'a des gens comme choriste
météo qui ont commencé à dire des choses
des choses qui avait un sens au point de
vue social les gens simplement générale
ont commencé à avoir une meilleure
éducation
c'est pas seulement la musique noire
seulement fait toute la musique
américaine
frank sinatra par exemple autrefois mais
chanter sur l'amour avec toujours des
choses comme ça maintenant c'est pas
possible on veut pas s'en tirer avec ce
genre de merde ou bien il faut chanter
des trucs qui n'ont aucun sens vraiment
d'une on sent clairement pour tout le
monde ou alors quelque chose avec lequel
on puisse identifier
alors je crois que c'est pas seulement
le problème de la musique noire c'est
toute la musique américaine qui devient
une forme un peu plus intelligente j'ai
point de vue des paroles peut-être une
des raisons pour lesquelles je me suis
mis à écrire mes propres chansons même
j'en suis sûr c'est parce que toutes les
chansons qu'on menait pour je les chante
été complètement idiot avec tous les
clichés
c'est mon grand désir
est en feu ça n'a même pas en français
alors on s'est dit si on doit avoir des
paroles sur les musiques il faut que ça
veut dire quelque chose je crois
simplement l'esprit des gens en général
qui s'y met à grandir un petit peu c'est
pour une question d'éducation dans le
sang ce livre est simplement que les
gens pensent un peu plus
quel genre de public avait fait aux
états unis maintenant passer un peu tout
le monde à peu près moitié moitié noir
et noir des jeunes des vieux
une des choses que je préfère c'est
quand il ya des gens un peu vieux qui
ont aimé cette chanson que j'ai écrits
qui sont ma grand-mère et on voit des
vielles dames qui viennent derrière la
scène et qui vous donne un gros baiser
humide très agréable je crois qu'il faut
que les gens aient quelque chose en
commun
maintenant il ya trop de choses un
conflit les jeunes contre les vieux les
noirs contre les blancs les juifs contre
les arabes les gens à cheveux longs
contre les gens à cheveux courts je
crois qu'il ya quelqu'un qui doit d'une
façon du nom se débrouiller pour qu'une
forme d'art puisse être connue à tout le
monde n'y a rien comme entre les gens
alors une des choses très satisfaisante
du public que j'ai eus où je devrais de
nous avons eu puisque nous sommes 5
j'ai vraiment d'avoir été capable de
faire quelque chose que les gens peuvent
avoir en commun au moins au moment
précis où ça se passe pendant l'heure où
ça se passe et ça c'est très
satisfaisant
[Musique]